Bonjour à tous alors il y a quelques jours j'ai essayé de partir en vacances avec mes potes aux Bahamas
voilà et puis en arrivant on a découvert cette
bah cette pluie. Il y a une sorte de tempête pluvieuse inattendue qui s'est abattue pile poil sur les Bahamas
la semaine où on y est. En fait c'est le décor des caraïbes avec le temps de la Bretagne...
C'est juste une catastrophe naturelle qu'on est en train de vivre là.
La Terre part en couille, il y a plus de saisons !
Qu'est-ce qu'on a à dire là-dessus. Quel est le commentaire ?
Bah écoute j'apprend à naviguer !
Est-ce qu'on peut dire que t'est une sorte de matelot ?
Exactement !
Et toi tu serais une sorte de mousse ?
Oui à tribord toute !
J'avoue quand on est arrivés on voulait dire à tout le monde qu'on était aux Bahamas sur les réseaux
pour ce la raconter hein comme tout le monde
sauf qu'on n'arrivait pas trop à assumer que le temps était pourrit du coup on montrait nos vacances mais pas complètement, hein, on montrait juste une partie.
Alors ici c'est ma chambre d'hôtel voilà avec une petite vue plutôt sympa
C'est pas la peine de faire rager les gens non plus c'est tu vois enfin... On est pas là pour ça...
Ouais c'est... Bon la vue elle est... On la montrera un autre jour.
C'est magnifique ! Waw !
Fait voir la vue.
Ah ouais quand même !!!
Cher papa, tu vois cette carte postale,
et ben elle ne correspond pas du tout à mes vacances
hein mois je suis carrément sous la flotte.
*rire* Je t'embrasse, ton putain de fils qui t'aime un max !
Ragez pas Paris !
Donc on est dans le jacuzzi avec les potes et regardez bien
y a vraiment un mec totalement habillé dans le jacuzzi
Oui !
Est-ce que vous avez des aimants en forme de pluie, c'est pour un souvenir ?
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comme activité ?
Les dauphins ?
Ouais quand il pleut c'est pas, euh, c'est pas génial...
C'est pas ouf ?
Hum...
Ah le voilier !
C'est un peu le même problème
Ouais
Quand il pleut...
Ah !!!
Je crois que j'ai une idée !
Puissance 4
Yes... On en refait une autre ?
Ok...
Yes...
Jusqu'au moment où j'ai eu une idée
Et si on rentrait ?
- Ouais !
- Yes !
Je vais faire ma valise !
On rentre à Paris !
Attendez, attendez en deux deux,
je viens de réfléchir là, avec la météo qui à si on part en avion maintenant...
Ca va être chaud...
Et puis finalement, bah on s'est mis à kiffer nos vacances.
On a juste pris du plaisir, et profité du cadeau qu'est la vie.
Parce que la vie est un cadeau hein,
on n'est pas souvent informé de ça mais c'est un cadeau ouais.
Allez tchin !
Contre toute attente alors qu'il fait extrêmement pas froid
mais très très humide hein il pleut énormément on prend du plaisir
à se baigner dans cette piscine avec le tonnerre au dessus de la tête.
Ouais !!!
Je suis gros !!!
*rire*
Très très grosse ambiance sur la plage.
*musique*
Alors on le re-dit jamais assez , pensez bien à mettre de la crème solaire et de la biafine et à vous mettre souvent à l'ombre,
surtout quand vous êtes aux Bahamas hein, c...
Et ben elle est pas mal cette vue...
Bon, si tu regardes pas les containers qui a en-dessous, parce que là c'est, c'est moins bien...
C'est marrant sur l'annonce de l'hôtel c'était pas écrit qui avait ça...
Et là bas c'est le château, le château des bofs !
*rires*
Des bofs un peu riches quand même
On vient de remporter le jackpot !
On vient de gagner une somme de oufs au casino c'est, euh, c'est "unbelievable" !!!
"Oh my god" !!! Près de un seul cen... Allez !!!!
Et c'est cadeau !
C'était un prank tou tou tou tou tou tou tou !
Ok ok alors coup de théâtre, dernier jour aux Bahamas, que se passe-t-il ? Le temps est idéal,
27 degrés, soleil de oufs, chaleur, aucun nuage, est ce qu'on est content là ?
on est très très contents.
Et là je vous emmène dans la "suicid forest" c'est une forêt
*rires*
où les gens se suicident et je pense que je vais filmer un pendu...
Allez dédicace à Logan Paul yeah !
Attendez, mais, il y a un problème là.
Je suis daltonien ou... Moi je vois vraiment l'eau turquoise
Olala mon gars !
C'est une turie !
Ok notre séjour aux Bahamas se termine ici,
on a tellement kiffés, on est au bout de l'île,
voilà ça marque vraiment la fin d'un séjour, d'un plaisir entre amis c'est vraiment énorme !!!
On se voit bientôt.
Enormes ces vacances les amis,
abonnez vous à ma chaîne youtube et cliquez sur la cloche pour recevoir les notifications
"Up the top" !
Sous-titres : Jules